thank you for that well a man convicted  of the brutal killing of his girlfriend  and her teenage son back in 2002 has  died while on death row now according to  the clark county coroner 48 year old  timmy t.j weber died at sunrise hospital  on may 18th now weber was serving a  death sentence at a state prison for  murdering kim and anthony gottier some  of the details are graphic now police  say kim gatier was beaten strangled and  stuffed in a plastic storage container  according to testimony at the trial  anthony died after being bound gagged  and left face down with a plastic bag  over his head and heavy weights on his  back right now the cause of death is  unknown